muriel pénicaud ministre du travail et
edouard philippe premier ministre ont
lancé l'application mon compte formation
au campus des services de l'automobile
et de la mobilité à guyancourt
cette application permet de s'inscrire
directement en formation sans passer par
un intermédiaire
l'objectif faire décoller la formation
professionnelle en france
il ya simplement une personne sur trois
qui vont en formation chaque année il ya
beaucoup plus d'aspiration évolué et
puis ya beaucoup plus ce souci
d'évolution des métiers on sait qu'on
avait en france un accès à la formation
professionnelle qui était très en deçà
des besoins très en dessous de ce qu'on
pouvait faire
et probablement parce qu'il y avait des
gens qui ne connaissaient pas leurs
droits
mon compte formation permet de connaître
ses droits à des formations puis de
trouver de réserver et de payer la
formation de son choix
sa patte en vouloir changer de métier
son entreprise pour un demandeur
d'emploi s'est trouvé un emploi il avec
une qualification on a trois fois plus
de chances de trouver un emploi
l'application est ouverte à tous les
salariés et demandeurs d'emploi patrie
pereira salarié d'une entreprise de
déménagement souhaitent se former au
parmi pour chariots élévateurs
il s'inscrit en direct avec son numéro
de sécurité sociale son email et en
créant un mot de passe je supporte une
et c'est parti demande d'inscription et
la l'organisme de formation à 48 heures
pour répondre
le compte est crédité de 500 euros par
an 800 pour les salariés non qualifiés
les formations diplômantes ou
certifiantes tourne autour des 1400
euros
il n'est pas très courant qu'on dise à
25 millions de français c'est beaucoup
quand même 25 millions de français vous
avez un droit et vous ne l'exercé pas
aujourd'hui mais grâce à ça vous allez
pouvoir l'exercer
plus de 100000 formations sont proposées
actuellement sur mon compte formation